Krispy Kreme Donuts has agreed to be acquired by a unit of JAB Holding Company...
...for about 1.35 billion dollars.
It's a combination the two companies hope will be as natural as coffee and donuts.
Sir, a dozen?
Okay.
JAB, a German private equity firm, will pay 21 dollars a share for the crispy confections...
...in a deal that would take the donut maker private.
JAB had been building a worldwide coffee empire in recent years.
In addition to acquiring coffee machine maker Keurig Green Mountain...
...for roughly 14 billion dollars,...
...they also acquired Caribou Coffee and Peet's Coffee and Tea.
That company already owned a majority stake in Intelligentsia Coffee...
...and Portland's Stumptown Coffee.
Krispy Kreme started out as a single store...
...in Winston-Salem, North Carolina in 1937.
It went public in 2000.
Shares in the widely popular chain climbed to nearly 50 dollars apiece in 2003.
But the company expanded so quickly that it landed in hot water...
...as goods and stores became pervasive.